♪
>> Will: AND WE ARE BACK WITH A
FOX NEWS ALERT.
AS AMERICA RETREATS FROM
AFGHANISTAN, IT DIDN'T TAKE LONG
FOR RUSSIA AND CHINA TO FILL THE
POWER VACUUM AS THEST ARE OF THE
WORLD WAS EVACUATING THEIR
EMBASSIES IN KABUL, NOT RUSSIA
AND CHINA, THEY WERE KEEPING
THEIR DOORS OPEN SIGNIFYING
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
THE TALIBAN WITH AMERICA OUT OF
THE PICTURE, CHINA IS NOW THE
MAJOR ECONOMIC FORCE IN THE
REGION.
RIOTERS SAID THE FOLLOWING:
CHINA CAN NOW DELIVER AID
INVESTMENT AND TECHNICAL SUPPORT
CHINESE STATE MINORS CAN HELP
AFGHANISTAN EXPLOIT ITS VAST
MINERAL RESERVES VALUED AT OVER
$3 TRILLION ACCORDING TO
OFFICIALS.
AND THAT'S FROM 2017.
BUT, AS THE COMMUNIST NATION
CLAMPS DOWN ON FREEDOMS IN HONG
KONG AND PREFERABLY IN TAIWAN IF
THEY HAD THEIR OWN WAY, THEY ARE
BEGINNING THEIR WARNINGS, THEY
TOLD THE TAIWAN KNEES PEOPLE
THIS THAT AMERICA WILL ABANDON
THEM, TOO.
LOOK AT THIS.
THIS IS FROM STATE MEDIA WHO
TWEETED FROM WHAT HAPPENED IN
AFGHANISTAN, THOSE IN TAIWAN
SHOULD FORESEE ONCE A WAR BREAKS
OUT IN THE STRAITS THE ISLAND
OFFENSIVE WILL COLLAPSE IN HOURS
AND U.S. MILITARY WON'T COME TO
HELP.
SO HAS OUR WITHDRAWAL EMBOLDENED
CHINA?
IS THIS ONE OF THE COSTS OF THE
COLLAPSE OF THE LAST 72 HOURS?
DAVID TAFURI IS A FORMER OBAMA
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL AND HE
JOINS ME NOW.
DAVID, THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
ME.
HOW DO YOU THINK PEOPLE ARE
SLEEPING TONIGHT IN TAIWAN?
I CAN'T IMAGINE SOUNDLY.
>> WELL, THAT TWEET IS FROM
GLOBAL TIMES.
GLOBAL TIMES IS JUST A NEWSPAPER
THAT'S A MOUTHPIECE FOR THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY.
SO THAT'S PROPAGANDA.
THAT'S CHINESE FEAR-MONGERING IN
TAIWAN, TRYING TO WORRY TAIWAN.
THE SITUATION BETWEEN AMERICA
AND TAIWAN IS VERY DIFFERENT
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
WE DON'T HAVE TROOPS IN TAIWAN,
HAVEN'T FOR A LONG TIME BUT WE
HAVE HAD OVER 70-YEAR ALLIANCE.
IT'S A COMPLICATED ALLIANCE BUT
WE HAVE STOOD BY TAIWAN.
>> Will: DAVID, LET ME INTERRUPT
YOU FOR A MOMENT.
THE TWO POINTS YOU MAKE SO FAR
WOULD MAKE THE TAIWAN KNEES
PEOPLE EVEN MORE NERVOUS.
YOU ARE TELLING ME A WARNING
CAME FROM OFFICIAL STATE MEDIA,
PROPAGANDA.
THAT MEANS THEY MIGHT MEAN WHAT
THEY SAY.
YOU POINT OUT THE GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T HAVE TROOPS IN TAIWAN.
AFGHAN PEOPLE WATCHED AS
THOUSANDS OF TROOPS ABANDONED
THAT COUNTRY IN A MATTER OF
HOURS.
SO IF YOU ARE LIVING IN A
COUNTRY WHERE AMERICAN TROOPS
HAD A PRESENCE AND NOW YOU ARE
LIVING UNDER THE RULE OF THE
TALIBAN, HOW DO YOU THINK PEOPLE
LIVING IN A COUNTRY WHERE THERE
IS NO AMERICAN TROOP PRESENCE
MUST FEEL WHEN THEY HAVE AN
OFFICIAL WARNING ON THEIR HANDS?
>> WELL, IT'S NOT NEWS TO THE
PEOPLE IN TAIWAN THAT CHINA
OPPOSES THEM AND OPPOSES THEIR
DEMOCRACY.
EVERYONE IN TAIWAN IS AWARE OF
THAT AND AWARE OF THAT THREAT.
>> Will: BUT IT MIGHT BE NEWS IF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
MIGHT NOT BE THERE TO BACK THEM
UP.
>> YEAH, WELL, I MEAN, LET'S
TALK ABOUT THAT.
YOU KNOW, THE VIDEOS ARE COMING
OUT OF KABUL ARE CONCERNING AND
SHOULD BE CONCERNING TO ALL.
BUT THE DEAL FOR US TO LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN WAS SIGNED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN FEBRUARY OF
2020.
AND PEOPLE SEEM TO FORGET THAT
ON YOUR SHOW.
IT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT DID
THIS DEAL.
IN FACT, UNDER HIS DEAL, HE
WOULD HAVE HAD ALL-AMERICAN
FORCES OUT OF AFGHANISTAN BY
MAY.
IT WAS BIDEN THAT EXTENDED IT
UNTIL SEPTEMBER.
SO THIS WAS A FORGONE CONCLUSION
THAT BIDEN FOLLOWED AFTER TRUMP
DID IT.
REMEMBER, ALSO, PRESIDENT TRUMP
GAVE 5,000 TALIBAN PRISONERS AND
RELEASED THEM.
IN ORDER TO GET THE DEAL A
PRETTY BAD DEAL IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
AND MANY OF THOSE 5,000 TALIBAN
FIGHTERS HAVE REJOINED THE
TALIBAN.
>> Will: DAVID, I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY ON THIS PROGRAM HAVE
WANT FORGOTTEN THAT TRUMP
LEAVING ACHING IT'S POSSIBLE YOU
MIGHT HAVE BEEN GETTING YOUR IFB
PLUGGED IN DURING THAT.
WE MAKE A POINT FACTUAL AND
TRUTH SEEKING POINT WHETHER OR
NOT WE LEAVE AFGHANISTAN WITH
HOW WE LEAVE AFGHANISTAN.
AND THE POINT WE ARE GETTING AT
TODAY IS WHO STEPS INTO OUR
VACUUM WHEN WE STEP OUT AND
LEAVE CHAOS?
THE WAY THAT JOE BIDEN AND OUR
MILITARY LEADERS HAVE LEFT IN
THE LAST 72 HOURS, WE SEE
IMMEDIATELY THAT OUR ADVERSARIES
IN CHINA AND RUSSIA STEP UP.
AND I WOULD HAVE TO THINK WE
DON'T HAVE TO FOCUS SPECIFICALLY
ON TIJUANA.
IF YOU ARE UNITED STATES ALLY IN
THE MIDDLE EAST, IF YOU ARE NOT
A UNITED STATES ALLY ANYWHERE IN
THIS WORLD, BUT MOST
SPECIFICALLY, IF YOU ARE A
UNITED STATES ALLY IN TAIWAN,
YOU WOULD LOOK AT THE LAST 72
HOURS AND THINK, I'M NOT SURE WE
CAN TRUST THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> YOU SEEM TO BE ARGUING THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE KEPT THE TROOPS
IN AFGHANISTAN FOR A LONG TIME
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
I THINK THERE IS AN ARGUMENT
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE.
ONCE PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED THE
DEAL TO PULL THE TROOPS OUT FROM
AFGHANISTAN, THIS WAS ALWAYS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHETHER IT WAS UNDER BIDEN OR
UNDER.
>> Will: JOE BIDEN ONE MONTH AGO
WHOA THEY SAID ONE MONTH AGO
THIS WOULDN'T HAPPEN THOUGH.
YOU SAID THIS WAS ALWAYS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
THAT'S THE SAME THING JOE BIDEN
SAID TODAY.
CAN I ROLL THE TAPE FROM LESS
THAN A MONTH AGO WHERE JOE BIDEN
WAS SAYING THIS WOULD NEVER
HAPPEN.
>> I THINK EVERYONE KNEW IT WAS
GOING TO EVENTUALLY HAPPEN IT
HAPPENED MORE QUICKLY.
THE TALIBAN GAINED STRENGTH VERY
QUICK THERE SNOWBALLED IN MANY
TOWNS AND CITIES.
THEY SWITCHED OVER HAD WHEN THEY
SAW THAT THE TALIBAN WAS GAINING
IN POWER BECAUSE THEY CARE MOST
ABOUT THEIR OWN SAFETY.
THAT'S WHY IT HAPPENED SO
QUICKLY.
BUT IT WAS ALL HAPPEN AND
ACTUALLY SO FAR, ALTHOUGH IT
LOOKS REALLY BAD.
IT'S NOT AS BAD AS IT COULD HAVE
BEEN.
THERE HAVE NOT REPRISAL KILLINGS
YET IN KABUL.
AND THERE MAY BE.
I WILL BE ONE OF THE FIRST
PEOPLE COMPLAINING ABOUT IT IF
IT HAPPENS THERE AREN'T SO FAR
YET REPRISAL KILLINGS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE TALIBAN
IS GOING TO DO.
THE TALIBAN IS COMMITTED TO
HAVING AN EXCLUSIVE GOVERNMENT.
I'M PERSONALLY VERY SKEPTICAL OF
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHO STILL BELIEVE
THE TALIBAN AND NOT THE TALIBAN
OF THE 1990s AND MIGHT HAVE
INCLUSIVE GOVERNMENT AND LET'S
SEE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Will: THE TALIBAN MIGHT JUST
HAVE AN INCLUSIVE GOVERNMENT.
RIGHT.
I'M SURE THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
ALL HOLD OUR BREATH TO SEE.
MAYBE THEY WILL FOLLOW, FOR
EXAMPLE, SOME OF THE GUIDANCE IN
THE UNITED STATES AND WE CAN
RENAME BREAST FEEDING CHEST
FEEDING.
I'M SURE THAT'S THE KIND OF
EXPECTATION WE CAN HOPE FOR.
>> I SAID I'M SKEPTICAL.
>> Will: I APPRECIATE THAT
SKEPTICISM.
I WILL TELL YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT SKEPTICISM.
I THINK IT'S MORE THAN
SKEPTICISM I THINK IT'S REALISM.
I HOPE IN THE UNITED STATES
FUTURE THE UNITED STATES BAR
ISN'T TO CROSS NO REPRISAL
KILLINGS.
I HOPE WE CAN DO BETTER THAN
MASS CHAOS AND LIES ONE MONTH
PERIOD OF TIME.
I HOPE WE HEAR BETTER THAN WE
HEARD FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IN THE LAST
MONTH.
THE PEOPLE OF TAIWAN AND ISRAEL
AND OVER OTHER ACROSS THE WORLD
HOPING, THAT MAY BE ALL THEY ARE
LEFT WITH IS HOPE BUT HOPING FOR
THE SAME THING FROM THIS GREAT
COUNTRY.
I APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH ME
TONIGHT, DAVID.
>> THA